plus de 800000 euros ce sont les
dommages et intérêts réclamés par la
famille d'alexia d'aval cette femme
assassinée par son mari joe natale en
octobre 2017
le délibéré rendu ce mardi à vesoul
retour en images sur une affaire très
médiatisée où se trouve alexia d'aval
cette femme de 29 ans parti de son
domicile hier matin pour un footing 29
octobre 2017
alexia d'aval disparaît près de gray en
haute-saône après un footing son mari
johnattan d'aval alerte la gendarmerie
les recherches commencent une battue est
organisée
j'espère que les blessés puissent pas se
déplacer et c'est ça qu'il empêche de
bouger
c'est ce que j'espère après un jour de
recherches
un corps est retrouvé dans un bois à
quelques kilomètres degrés difficile
alors de dire s'il s'agit de la jeune
femme
si le corps d'un individu
hommes ou femmes plutôt jeunes qui est
fortement dégradée puisqu'il semblerait
qu'effectivement la personne qui l'a
amené là brûlée mais l'adn a parlé
il s'agit bien du corps d'alexia dans la
région l'émotion est immense
le 5 novembre plus de 8000 personnes
participent à une marche blanche à gré à
la tête du cortège
la famille de la victime dont son mari
johnattan qui apparaît comme un veuf
éploré
à cet instant personne ne sait encore
qu'il est le meurtrier
la force de notre couple nous faisons
nous dépasser dans nos sorties et dans
notre vie commune après trois mois
d'enquêté la sphère s'emballe le 29
janvier 2018 johnattan d'avaler mis en
garde à vue
un voisin affirme avoir entendu la
voiture du couple sortir la nuit
précédant la disparition d'alexia
éléments cas toujours nier johnattan
finalement le principal suspect craque
et avoue le crime oui il l'a étranglée
dans un moment lorsqu'on peu après des
violences volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort sans intention de la donner c'est
comme ça que le droit appelle ça et
qu'après il a été dépassé par tous
malgré ses aveux la sphère ne s'arrête
pas là le 4 juillet 2018 ou théâtre
nouveau revirement johnatan d'aval
accuserait désormais sa belle famille
d'avoir scellé un pacte secret et
viserait selon l'est républicain
son beau frère grégory gay en
particulier selon d'aval son beau frère
aurait étranglé la victime après une
crise d'hystérie d'alexia mais cette
accusation ne tient pas et le suspect
revient à sa version initiale quelques
mois plus tard c'est bien lui qui a tué
alexia le 16 novembre 2020
son procès s'ouvre à vesoul johnatan
d'aval a été condamné à 25 ans de
réclusion criminelle
[Musique]